what's up King of the sting got a king
and a stinger for you guys uh I saw this
video on Instagram of these uh [ __ ]
wrestlers and uh they look a little
twacked out which might make it better I
don't know but uh yeah what's your guys
opinion on it uh [ __ ] wrestling
cracked out gang gang buzz buzz sword
nice
I mean everyone's just trying to get
there
[Music]
right down micro violence come follow us
on micro Tick Tock micro Wrestling
Federation he says eyes not creepy that
little one is oh and sweet boom mic in
the shot listen listen small because
they gotta you guys not tall enough
they're the cameramans they're not tall
I know the guys are saying or the
cameraman's not tall enough
oh they're not calling up
boom guy's like we're not we can't hear
it much you gotta bring it down yeah
yeah uh here's a question Eric how many
of those little men do you think you'd
take on at one time here's a better
question how many do you think you fit
in your anus
to it yeah yeah the one on the far left
kind of I can fit the whole micro
Federation in there well I don't know
how tall these guys really are but they
look dangerous look at the windows
dangerous
dangerous dangerous to what facet can
they put a quarter next to them so I can
get some scale
next time put like a a gatorade bottle
on the ground so we can no could you
just put a my pet monster next to him so
you know see what kind of house is
actually one story it looks like
um that's actually a Barbie house I
think that uh you know everyone's just
trying to get their money dude let them
get their money [ __ ] it you know what I
mean let them get their money well I
mean as long as you're like well that
guy looks regular as long as you're into
it like second one I would hate for them
to like these like if they feeling I
don't know if they're feeling exploited
I mean even these neanderthals that
we're doing UFC felt exploited by UFC so
this is even like they're being
exploited double but they're signing up
for that and they're also they probably
like it right yeah do they that's all
I'm saying as long as everybody involved
is having a good time I'm not even
trying to be [ __ ] do they have many
options no I know but this could happen
I mean you know they could be [ __ ]
like I don't know
yeah I'll tell you what though all the
small people that that forehead you
wouldn't want to do a head button
competition with any of them they would
be Elvis in their butt Chris
that's the real question of the three of
these
like who would you what style of
dwarfism would you want you know far
left he's bobbied up clearly very sexy
far left looks like a mini rock also
terrible question the far left is
actually really a little bit no he is or
he's seven
the middle guy looks like I don't know
here's a plus about being a small person
this is just science that you've never
seen a small person with a flat ass it's
impossible they all have cheeks they're
all cheek dumb and that's science
officially why they can't fit in the
overhead compartment yeah because they
they could if it wasn't for the [ __ ]
cakes they have you know that